coûte le plaisir partagé de changer un
petit peu de tourner
ouais ça permet de sape et ça fait des
émissions différentes à chaque fois on
fait du stream sera lé là tes côtés mais
ça se peut ok je roule à fond ouais
c'est bien d'autres opposants ouais
ouais voilà ces histoires il lance un
peu la tradition puis après je me mets
un peu dans les roues quoi tu vois je
récupère mais je vais vous laisser
rouler à deux quoi devant et j'en
reviens après je me suis connecté vite
et j'ai vu qu'avec femme vous êtes c'est
complètement partie en délire les
poubelles des verts football manager oui
on a fait signer peter scène premier
match triplé au bout de 30 minutes quoi
ouais on l'a payé 5 millions
donc bon après il est un peu nul on a un
nom c'est marrant parce qu'on s'est
écrit ce matin pour faire les stratégies
pour le prochain stream qu'on est en
mode wi pieters est très bien fatigué
clou ils sont cons de dionis n'a pas
voulu partir on a dégagé personnes en
charge de dégager des joueurs à sion
mais oui mais à 3 millions personnes le
voeu donc mais bon favalli on veut plus
voir sa gueule ou alors on va le faire
vous on va se [ __ ] de sa gueule
pendant tout le match
tu es nul tu ne marques pas mérite
admettait un peu regardé du coup
l'épopée outé j'aime me suis connecté
j'ai regardé la victoire fait je faisais
un article du coup j'ai mis au fond en
même temps j'ai pas bu vous en étiez que
je suis vous avez complètement craqué
c'était marc webb on a fait soudain sa
chance ouais on a commencé on a mis
longtemps à commencer la saison a mis
une heure à faire l'entraînement la
tactique les recrues les machins 20
normal du coup mais bon on va continuer
on veut au moins faire la première
saison
tentez la qualif en ldc et si on va en
ligue des champions écoute si ça peut
sourire quoi après on sait pas un faut
continuer ensuite à baawiza ici on va
avoir une passion je suis viré en fait
on recommencera pas de zéro tu vois on
est dedans mais c'est sûr de ça au tchad
après ça peut être l'objectif des
siennes se faire bien vu notre
management à mon avis très très possible
quand on est très énervé on essaie
d'acheter des joueurs complètement
ridicule enfin on fait n'importe quoi
mais bon on va on s'amuse bien là ce
soir peut-être on va faire été un flop
ailleurs chez payot mais j'ai des potes
qui sont sur chose qui me motive pour dj
justement des mois j'ai jamais joué
enfin j'ai joué comme ça de trois fois
mais je pense que je tente et on joue
avec un peu ils ont l'habitude de plus
les joueurs déjà que si ça se trouve il
me regarde mes moyens
il s'agit d'un emploi football manager
aussi ou pas je crois pas moi j'ai
beaucoup joué
j'aurai une dizaine d'années vous est
vachement de paris mais sans balle ce
qu'ils y arrivent des champions 58 cool
on était assez chaud stade hot pot car
nous sommes pas rien mais il parle si tu
nous vois stream un jeu comme ça et tout
à écrire sur l'ice bouquet à passer quoi
fois tu vois la cse des soirées délire
on s'en fout tu vois on est là mais
famille les chemins pour le jeu était
enfin il est concentré il y a bien senti
ces sorties que femme
ouais la sévère dans l'état d'esprit
mais je pense quand on l'a vu contre
oignons ça a été extraordinaire quoi
faire je pense qu'il va se mettre en
condition non mais c'est bien pastore
qui connaît tous les joueurs y connait
tous les prêts à sainté icône est super
bien forcément et il connaît même les
gars de l'équipe de y
ce matin guy with johnny je laime déjà
pas en vrai là il nous faut encore la
merde dans le dans l'effectif tu vois ce
qu'il va prendre le truc très à coeur
ouais tu sens qu'on va être saison 2022
filtre en même temps complètement sera
fini le temps à parvenir à la vraie vie
poti déraille complètement alors menti à
l'aréna ouais je vais m il ya quand même
des gens qui écrivent rouge et bleu sont
de couleur lione notre coeur à 10 ans
s'arrête ça va être beau et tu vois quoi
sinon à part moi je jouais beaucoup à
heroes à l'époque si vous en avez parlé
à zéro partout et déjà les uns ce jeu
j'adorais ce jeu là même une espèce de
deux compétitions internationales en
fait c'était un truc un peu un peu de
niche cachet mais où les mecs étaient
juste c'était des objets namous quoi le
moindre mouvement sur la map qui était
calculé mais j'étais que c'était un
c'est un jeu génial c'est pour moi c'est
un des meilleurs jeux auxquels j'ai joué
heroes bon tour partout on va quand même
mais moi j'aime que les tour par tour là
moi je suis pas fan plus de jusqu'à la
course à la sauver quoi pour ça qu'être
jacques j'ai un peu peur ah oui tu en a
les mêmes goûts bader façon l'échec
poker déjà ya c'est vrai que ça partait
un peu dans le même délire quoi
meilleure osmose avec le retrouver pour
monsieur deux pas des choses ouais
carrément il y avait aussi une idée
c'était de faire un civilisation mais
avec eux des joueurs humains
brune france fait une vraie civilisation
bah voilà ya des idées il ya des idées
n'est ce pas un macaron réfléchir pour
le tournoi alors si un tournoi il
manquait juste une journée de plus pour
real que le règlement autorise a déclaré
liverpool champion jpp club luminator
coulant sur wii presque la raison de la
catastrophe
leur poule palmarès pas fait pas de
palmarès et je me disais aussi le psg en
sueur pour une fois qu'il se crée il
suffit si la ligue des champions bah je
pense qu'à liverpool aura titre avance
même si officiellement ils peuvent pas y
je pense que ça va se terminer comme ça
et là j'ai dit un truc un peu enfin un
peu inquiétant fin par rapport aux
sports évidemment donc c'est passé rien
mais à genre l'australie veulent annuler
leur leur tournée en novembre dans
l'hémisphère nord au rugby et tu vois
c'est genre ça commence à annuler des
trucs en novembre quoi ouais c'est pas
très bon signe ouais et le dernier
article que j'ai lu il ya pas longtemps
ça parlait de
ouais de retour à la vie normale entre
un an et 18 mois quoi qu'en dise normal
c'est normal normal ou tour marcherez
comme avant quoi c'est énorme mais pour
la santé au jour le jour c'est vraiment
ouais on sait pas comment ça va compte
que ça va avancer mais bon j'ai envie de
te dire c'est moins pire que ce que je
pensais le confinement le machin ça va
voilà un traîneau si l'habitude d'être
sur l'ordi certainement pas le plus
affecté par ça sur le long terme
non ça peut devenir pays mais je pensais
en fait je pensais qu'après une semaine
dix jours on aurait déjà vraiment marre
je t'aime bien aller faire des tours à
pied finalement ça fait un peu plus de
deux semaines est franchement
enfin ça fait deux semaines aujourd'hui
mais bon moi je faisais déjà gaffe le
week end avant donc on va dire que ça
fait 2 mai à ça va le fait de pouvoir
juste sortir autour de chez soi à
marcher dix minutes de temps en temps ça
permet de souffler chez patois mais là
le truc n'est pas trop fait pour
l'instant
d'ailleurs j'ai une mission en cours ce
qui m'attend là après le stream
j'espère que je reviendrai sain et sauf
mais oui oui le truc que je suis en
centre-ville où c'est quand même pas
l'aider à remarcher c'est pas génial
oui oui c'est bien avec ta femme c'est
déjà un bon point
ouais moi qui suis mariée mais bon d'un
autre côté si mon travail avec ma femme
sur les divorcés donc tout le monde
donnait pas à ce stade donc du coup les
ouates et était seule tout quoi
là je la route social chez moi c'est pas
mal aux siens ouais c'est différent
on s'habitue bien à glander quand même
j'ai passé quatre appels pour le boulot
ce midi je suis épuisée ludivine se
doter c'est faux et c'est pas faux avec
le nom a changé voire on l'a fait la
couv arena maintenant contre rennes
kova rennais jusqu'en un petit peu les
réguler habituel ouais on a maugréé
foley on a barbarians et m'a dit 72
bobby fischer 0,02 à mon avis à bien il
y avait une banane verte qui va arriver
mk des players je passe tu te rappelles
on a déjà vu ici
ouais ça me dit quelque chose pour le
pin à tort bien sûr j'adore toujours là
et je pense qu'on va avoir à une grille
tacle qui était mal hier et hier il
arrive à 100 sans toi il craque esprit
du black barre n'était pas avec lui
ouais
du coup ça se passait pas très bien ces
blacks marc ans seulement et mac mini
personnages connus le boulot traverser
paris en voiture c'est un délice
ouailles j'imagine pour les gens qui
sont en voiture dans des grandes villes
comme ça il ya des embouteillages ça
devrait faire plaisent c'était carrément
leur changer d'avis ouais non c'est
chaud ça lucas les liens demande de saab
us enfin des joueurs sérieux
enfin des joueurs très sérieux ce que
joss ouais bah ça on se connaît on se
connaît se connaît quoi ok je suis allé
dormir chez lui tu vois je connais je
connais je connais de monsieur vous êtes
un sou
voilà on est intime on a dormi ensemble
dans la même pièce et pas qu'en jeu
quand même vrai on a posé deux lignes
différemment j'avais un lit
bon fiable sacré quand même des tas bien
ce genre complètement complètement lui
ai dit d'en annoncer pas lui qui dit
dans le hockey on peut participer à
l'aréna alors faut remettre les deux
liens et le club attend je trouve être
les liens d'ailleurs ouais ça me je sais
pas si tu veux un petit peu parlé de ce
projet qu'on a eue alors ces avancées
avant ce qui est merci pour moi pour le
simple merci akabla yens pour le seul
merci tonton way cette idée de d'essayer
de faire des petits interclubs est pas
parce que c'est une bonne idée mais que
tu avais effectivement parce que je
savais que tout est interrompu
on sait pas s'il pourra reprendre aller
au bout autant profiter et donc mais
sienne motivé bad et a forcément que des
gros clubs me suis fait juste d'être
d'être motivé d'avoir envie choo est
elle suffisamment nombreux d'avoir des
personnes pour l'habitude de jouer sur
internet et du coup de faire une petite
compétition entre papa une dizaine de
clubs espèce de championnat de france
des clubs
line et sous un format un petit peu
comme les matchs pour ceux qui ont
l'habitude de le faire par exemple
france serbie france acer vachon c'est à
dire que les lois d'une équipe vous de
minéraux ou l'autre équipe le numéro
deux et ainsi de suite
et puis ensuite on veut mixer un peu les
cadences on peut faire du un coup de pub
l'aide d'un coupe oui ce même parti ont
dix minutes fait le total ensuite un
petit championnat en place environ un
champion de france 2 des clubs de
tchatche.com ouais ça peut être sympa
faudrait il faut qu'on faut qu'on voit
avec le staff de chelsea comme du coup
mais du coup je resterai toi qui se mit
chapeauterait ce truc là je serai grand
chapeau que tu poserait sur la
compétition on va essayer de créer une
hache à deux doigts de créer une page
pour que les gens puissent s'inscrire et
puis faire un petit un genre de tableau
et tout fraîchement ça peut vraiment
être très cool hein je sais pas ce que
vous avez dans le 4 on n'hésitait pas à
ça
vous pensez que votre club patente est
d'ailleurs monsieur déjà autour de vous
[Musique]
ouais j'ai bien sûr ce sera ce sera
streamé l'idée c'est de savants mag est
quand même assez sympa s'est pas départi
donc été d'abord va pas faire des
parties en plastique
oui mais non c'est sympa sympa c'est un
gars de l'équipe qui stream après c'est
pas obligatoire mais ça peut être un
vrai plus quoi karaboue illégal pour
l'instant partait plus sûrs d'être trois
parties une horde de plus une pour le
bullet et que ça reste quand même des
échecs
une enceinte plus 0 par exemple 10 + 2
ouais c'est sympa c'est un peu ce qu'on
fait dans le match des équipes
nationales jouent pas comme ça la world
franchement c'est sympa balle au format
plutôt cools à suivre a commenté c'est
quand même assez rapide il se passe des
trucs on s'endort pas sur un coût de 45
minutes degré de chou et c'est assez
vivement et puis ça permet aux gens qui
n'ont pas trop le temps de celui qui
vous dit que le bullet il ya que dix
minutes pas il peut faire que il peut
jouer que dix minutes celui qui veut
jouer tout le truc ça dure un peu plus
d'une heure à tous suivant le temps que
tu as en fait tu peux participer à un
match de match 3
la liberté totale tu peux le faire
remplacer ce n'était pas le but l'aide
oui mais toutes façons de les plus
petits lots il joue pas contre l'autre
équipe au final donc dans tous les cas
tu es tu es tranquille quoi
le but c'est de garder certaine
souplesse oui enfin c'est la tranquille
épouse
j'adore ce terme p pouze épouse
sympathique je suis déçu parce que quand
j'étais chez winamax pour faire la
petite interview ouais il y avait un
gars qui a un super t-shirt épouse avec
un mec les cous quoi et
je n'arrive pas à trouver le t-shirt
mais j'essaie super mec est vraiment
épouse et sa fille combien alireza
hennebelle on n'a pas regardé jusqu'au
bout avec femme mais je crois quand on
arrêter cette douce pour ali reza ils
ont fixé sur la chasse comme ils ont vu
l'été aurait donc dû les télés auquel va
sa nouvelle spectaculaire échouage où
les insultes
ouais c'est ça s'est mal passé s'est pas
très bien passé mais mvl ils menaient
5-0 après il ya eu 13 très simple c'est
pris 13 08 à 13h et objets de dire des
grossièretés excuses et la demoiselle et
ils ont fini à 20,13 on nous dit le
torture mais assez chaud en avoir pris à
13,01 moment surtout en bus l'aise
ouais mais l'autre été en reste et a
pris le faisait beaucoup tomber un ouais
ok là dutil d'un forcément mais à celle
des coûts
ok alors on a un choc direct j'ai vu
qu'il y avait des mots dax d'inscrits tu
connais pas je leur demande et chip
pablo miaou
même si ou pas ce qu'on peut dire ce
qu'on veut passons maintenant c'est fait
on et a du coup tête de série numéro 1
mais lui c'est lui de fer dont je
parlais de la job tout à l'heure il est
brun age of bon jouer à age of alors son
frère est meilleur que lui à priori
remet même si certaines me qui
s'attaquent insa taquine alors attends
redemande les liens ouais je remets ça
jouer les contrats liés les uns aux
quais à l'écart ou qu il a gagné
j'avais vu une fois je me rends semblent
toutes les parents s'il a dit reza est
mieux voir canio il libère de toutes
celle inverse de mv elle allie réserve
il a refusé plein de fois les mieux
adaptés à chaque fois quatre à bichat où
il est impressionnant on en parlait hier
avec fab et c'est juste incroyable
différences de niveaux en plus sur
internet entre hikaru et les autres
alors après william hague new skies est
au dessus mais après tu un gars qui
disait un truc assez vrai aussi dans le
chat il nous disait que magnus il était
plus fort pic à rouen 1 v1 mais il car
il était super fort pour farm les
joueurs plus faibles sa spécialité la
pression là-dessus
ouais je me disais qu'il y avait le
match pierre feydeau ses gaffes aussi
nepomniachi bien vu un autre match j'en
refais de sega qui je crois qu'il a
gagné 15 12 mais apprennent et pau il
joue pas à fond un métier la can perdue
le mac et moi je me rappelle avoir vu
une adoption un 10-0 de naka contre les
ocf d'assez fou ouais ouais même assez
fou de mettre 10 0 fedosseeva force de
cette fois c'est fou et comme ça on
discutait avec le chat en tchador
tranquille 1 mêlez vous de la part des
contrats entre des soviets a priori
c'est ça concentré à 100%
même si on n'a pas de caméra ministre
impa je prends pas là il s'est mis au
stream mais non même si jouer au bâton
ce mot stremme en fait en ce moment
du coup et c'est la mode basse et bien
je verrai streamer c'est un trait sur
charges commencé il ya assez longtemps
effectivement si tu agis pensez y à rien
de regarder une vidéo avec femme un mec
qui posté sur facebook une vidéo qu'il a
fait il ya dix ans et je le rappelle dit
rafa tu vois il ya dix ans quand même
jeudi le matos est tout juste quand même
chaud et puis après j'ai en fait non
mais attends moi j'ai commencé il ya
huit ans hindi quoi en fait il ya huit
ans et demi ça se faisait déjà très bien
le stream en réalité c'était un peu mon
puits dur d'avoir une bonne qualité mais
ça se faisait en fait ouais mais pour
les échecs c'était quand même très rare
ah bah ouais ouais bah il y avait il n'y
avait pas énorme de ce territoire
français avait personne way en anglais
avait pas grand monde mais à mes joueurs
par là que d'un niveau matériel c'était
il ya dix ans c'était déjà il y avait
déjà les logiciels et tout ce qu'il
fallait pour le faire c'était pas
insurmontable
ouais c'était juste que la mode était
balancé mon corps ouais et que les gens
savaient pas que trop comment faire mais
j'avais déjà au ps tu avais déjà tant
fait avaient déjà tous les programmes et
sa tournée très bien et c'était tu avais
pas besoin d'un ordi 12 mois j'avais pas
un mordu de où vous n'avez pas besoin
d'un ordi de vous fait quel marché très
bien notamment dans le chat qui est le
meilleur joueur de tous les temps d'un
prêt de jeux sauvetat déjà répondu à
cette question un paquet de fois et donc
du coup je te laisse répondre
merde je me suis auto puni c'est
difficile un de faire ce choix tao parce
que là comme tu as pu dire toi de
comparer les époques et quelque chose de
baboo pas dedans donc je n'aurais jamais
dû relever cette question arrivée à
redon regarde pas et si je devais
choisir
j'ai peut-être fischer quand même bien
le goût était seul contre tous
mais j'adore table bien sûr mais après
je pense pas que par contre il se
considérait comme le meilleur de tous
les temps
ainsi à une belle fourchette jeune parti
mais il se fait complètement dominé la
fringale brutale c'est peut-être jour le
plus spectaculaire de tous les temps
mais sûrement vers mon fort voilà quatre
par offre aussi tu as honte écrit dans
le tchat
oui bien sûr kasparov carlson peut-être
avoir d'ici dix ans comment évoluer sa
carrière car la traîne mais s'il
continue sur sa lancée il est bien parti
il est déjà parti pour détrôner tour moi
j'en mets toujours détacherait quand
même 4 car la scène casse par an fischer
est elle capable rouquin dont les
joueurs aillent ce que j'allais dire
filiale équine aussi un l et qu'il était
assez incroyable aussi à ceux des
banques
c'est tellement dur en réalité de thé
tâche est comme ça
comment s'appelle le lotti un logiciel
mais cette chaise point com qui fait le
truc le taux de précision la caps le
carce voilà c'est que casablanca par
exemple les caps incroyablement élevé
pour son époque
ouais parce qu'il faut comprendre avec
le cap ce truc important et c'était
d'ailleurs écrit dans le dans l'article
de jazz comme c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils
peuvent réciter 15 à 20 coups
d'ordinateurs au début donc forcément ça
augmente leur caps largement oui est
capable en car oui il ya main caps de
fou mais capable encasté quelque chose à
kananga événement puisse y jouer vite et
invite on sentait qu'il y avait un côté
très très cinéma et il bossait pas
beaucoup il pas rien c'était pas renoncé
c'est intéressant c'est l'incarnation
talent à l'état pur jeu qui comprend la
tuer mais une position il s'est à chaque
fois qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et le
pas la capote masqué qui dit paul murphy
paul murphy aussi mais c'est au cas où
tu as de quoi
ouais mais c'est tellement tôt que les
gens voulaient passer avant le début de
l'ère où les gens ont commencé à
vraiment bien jouer quoi il était un peu
encore à sedan cet air là où ça n'allait
pas très bien quoi elle serait qu'il
pouvait avoir de serre valoir ou faut
faire un petit peu ce prix de beauté
c'est partie spectaculaire ya un côté il
avait parfois les victimes de l'idéal
serait beaucoup plus dur est de placer
la même chose des joueurs bien plus
solide à tenon est complètement
complètement complètement mais après son
sens tactique était quand même très
affûté quoi mission on sait pas s'il
avait joué contre des joueurs plus forts
peut-être qu'il aurait joué plus en
russie
voilà en fait ça te fait progresser
aussi dans ce monde ça te tiens vernon
donc pas vraiment pas vraiment ça mon
nom c'est la question c'est vraiment la
question piège et tu as tellement de
joueurs qui ont eu des talents talent de
fous ils ont tous apporté à leur manière
vous l'affrontez un truc jolie la
regardent leurs processus d'albert oui
peut-être
branges les cinq aussi un moment donné à
voir les marchés ont saisi
l'objet de reprenant celle ci c'est ce
que son projet 5 your hat on promet 6
intermédiaires qui attaquent la dame et
du ku'damm berne vous prend g5 d'un
droit de jeu prouvent 3
il apparut année peut le faire
maintenant
aïe le fait maintenant comme ça y est ce
que ça change quelque chose non
l'héroïne on fera ça change ça lui a
donné et tour a donné l'occasion à
l'adversaire de fer tourcoing quelque
chose comme ça ouais
du coup il va gagner une qualité
mes positions encore assez fermé donc
chemin ou trois pour défendre des quatre
voilà c'est bien de jouer
il fait gagner une bonne percée avec les
blancs gravatar ouais grave à tort avec
un petit widget en images mais bon faut
quand même qu'il fasse gaffe ses
positions là c'est pas aussi facile que
ça nous semble à gagner wave 2 je pense
que c'est bien joué quand même pour
défendre cette de faiblesse ou g33 après
question c'est ce que je peux faire à
cinq cavaliers âgés les bouffer des
quatre buts et quatre ya pas la dame ou
b6 je sais pas si mince oui désolé
désolé et du coup les blancs autant
d'aller organiser leurs pièces de
replacer leurs cavaliers en fait ils
contrôlent les deux colonnes liberté ici
c'est vraiment ce qui fait la différence
dans cette position ça permet de limiter
contre jeu parce que si la dame noire
menace infiltrait seraient plus en
danger avec les blancs même si c'est
bien joué mais aussi un petit peu de
créer quelque chose
il a parfois des airs pourquoi certains
en possède cette dame je sais pas trop
n'a pas vu le tout début on est bien
d'accord
normalement je devrais prendre et 6 bah
oui c'est naturel alors qu'il fasse
attention à des dames à cinq ans même
parfois que vous êtes problème
je pense qu'à damas un kurde à marseille
peut faire très mal je suis un guerrier
du matériel a priori on est très peu
tenté le volume sur le roi même match
qui va manquer
d'artificiers pour mener à bien toute la
dame va pour prendre le pouls p5 et
revenir en défense courir quoi non plus
on n'a quand même pas mal de défenseurs
c'est une blague dans les parties soient
aussi à plus de défenseurs que
d'attaquants très improbable que
l'attaquant coût de 6 vers ce genre d'
attaques désespérées tu les fais ça
avait du sens elles ont le mot désespéré
dedans parce que tu sais quand tu peux
plus rien faire d'autre tu tentes ça et
l'adversaire peut se tromper un oui est
du coup donné si je pense que la
meilleure chance pratiquer bhagwan gras
tg3 mais c'est pas si grave
là je pense par contre c'est important
de manger le fou si tu manges le carré
lisse ça serait peut être très dangereux
là tu peux avoir des pancakes rhône 3
parce que tu peux qualifier le bain
alors d'être fort celle du fou enfin
avoué fins et beaubien jeu sami sais je
travaillais g4 pour un minima avoir des
pertes est donc de se tromper il a pris
beata prix nous écoute enfin une riche
territoire
j'aurais peut-être compter qu'ils
s'écartent ici ouais c'est un conte
empêcher la dame de revenir
ce qui est dommage c'est que du coup
après après cavaliers prouve trois cas
la victoire du cavalier j k way pour
essayer de jouer ça ok tu as mais telle
chance pratiques ou monde perpète l'ordi
défense a comme en effet d'amélia dans
trois nations aux cavaliers 3 l'arrière
cavaliers la effet échec les façons il
revient aux quais why not
4 aïe défend le pion donc ya pas de perp
est l'apanage de darnets 4 pierre
laurent laurent sera la suite à un peu
short nom et du canada les trois oui
fallait comprendre que tu vois c'est pas
c'est toi trop bien pratique sans oubli
de verser la partie mais il ya pas
choquer
d ok oui contrôler ses mythes qui parle
aux maths c'est wittmann qui traînait
s'avoue cavaliers ouais je vous comment
fait que les blancs ici i'm narcy
dernier trois dames sert non t'inquiète
de revient est une fois ces genres de
position du peintre comme pas paniquer
prendre le permettent d'apprendre le
père pète c'est un peu plus être un mec
là où il a joué deux fois oui mais
menace rien il d'un autre aux échecs il
part d'un de trois échecs mais mais tu
vois la différence dans le cavalier en b
6 août pas la voir c'est que dans une
variante humaine à ce match là tu n as
pas mal qui peut faire dame g3 le retour
et file à un répit en fait déposer de
poèmes d'alger 3 c'est bien joué je
pense aux cavaliers 3 et ben yahia 15
secondes donc j'aï lâche le fou je pense
que je l'aurais pris le pouls sans
grande hésitation clairement les 200
premiers craquage galy trouve des bonnes
recrues ne pas se laisser faire ça joue
bien côté français je sens que des
gravats temps il a senti le vent tourner
et l'aurait secouée aurait pas d'
anarchiste avec les doigts pour
française aurait pu les lapins de tous
oui j'aurais pu tenter a prévu de 8 8
juillet bien s'arrêter le beau jeu mais
la wii s'est planté plus qu'avec les
plans ouais c'est ne pas ramener une
pièce en défense c'est ce que tu es
saâda buzz que la voilà typiquement
quand on a beaucoup de matériel d'avant
ça sert à rien de se donner encore plus
mais faut juste essayer de limiter le
contre 2 h 15 au maximum faire des choix
pas forcément la ligne et le remords 10
100 foot ça faire des choix plus
sécurisé ont en tout cas belle partie
meddle partie à rebondissements
la succession de gambie avec les noirs
contre 4 alors moi j'en ai un way qui
est sympa c'est le 4-5 cavalière 3 qui
avait des risques et prend le 5d 5 et je
continue comment si on prend dame prend
souvent les gars te font dames 2 g 5
car il est ici souffre aussi sky prend
la fuite qui sait si ce but l'attaqué à
la bombe orbite à nos qualités
ouais mais c'est très fort en fête est
devenu une partie comme ça ces trois
grand rodez 4 et à carnon ici je prends
les blancs sur fond noir paru déjà
gagnant vrai mais en fait cette position
là je l'avais un peu analysé maintenant
j'ai oublier bien sûr mais il se trouve
que cette position n'est pas si clair
ouais mais ça m'étonne pas une telle
avance de développement oui la dame
empêche le foot se développer dans cette
devise à vie dans la colonne des plantes
pratique c'est un petit gambie qui venge
pas de marche pas si tu en es un autre
contre kas avec les noirs sur e4 pas
trente-six truc non plus j'aime bien non
il n'y a pas grand chose il ya des
blancs combien options n'ont perdu
aucune je sais pas trop après tu as le
talgo envie de la scandinave
quatre des cinq qui comprend et sait si
ce n'est pas terrible ah ouais n'est pas
terrible me semble pas ce nom il est
jouable mais je venais pas de zoom
je pense que c'est ce qu'on dit d'amour
quand tu sais mieux pas terrible sur ce
qui n'est pas est pas obligé de
l'accepter quoi le mieux c'est pas
l'accepter du punch non non il faut
l'accepter mais j'ai su faire d'écart ça
va aussi
bon là ça se passe bien pour ses bagues
et qui en plus elles changent les dames
avec sa pièce de plus
donc il a bien raison c'est un bon
réflexe
il est une pièce de plus simplifié au
maximum le contre granby adélaïde gambie
avec les cinq questions plus intéressant
que sur ces troubles
c'est trop facile donc tu as ta vie ta
maroc wattao qui te poser une question
sur les gambier il a encore un gambit
qui lui étaient proposées le barbier de
ton une réputation assez sulfureuse com
[Musique]
oui mais qui peut être piégeux à tous
si tu connais pas du tout tu peux vite
trompeuses et l'horrible camby des temps
libres pinata racing connaît en phase
avec ça pas très bien se passer
il a vécu des traumatismes dominateur
sur le groupe benetton sheikh hasina hui
à 14 84 4 5 mais bon faut tomber sur un
guéridon virois si vous cherchez des
gambier aller sur une base de données
taper schirrhein si vous allez trouver
plein de l'ouverture rigolotes ou
suicidaire il suicidaire oui bon il
avait des bons résultats n'ont pas faim
mais bon c'était un sacré joueur réussit
pas c'est un mec il perdrait même ça
c'est tu sentais rien qu'en plus dégagé
aussi quelque chose à l'échiquier
français du sang que quelqu'un
d'intelligent qu'un un truc donc même
région des ouvertures ont mis deux
perdants il était capable de retourner
des grands maîtres
il jouait il jouait beaucoup en france
ouais mais tu connais sur l'histoire
c'est terrible la 2499 et je sais pas
combien d'hommes genre si nord où cette
norme le grand maître mais du coup il a
jamais des grands maîtres en trois lots
c'est dommage parce que c'est un des
joueurs les plus spectaculaires
oui oui il aurait vraiment mérité le
titre c'est juste ouais c'est un joueur
il est encore il encore envie de 6
il joue encore au nom mais joue encore à
50 il a ses actifs
ça fait longtemps que je n'ai pas hésité
pas à croiser j'ai déjà vu son j'allais
jouer contre lui c'était rigolo aussi il
abandonne jamais joué de finale c'était
en barcelone
j'avais quelques bons passages in plus
en finale
le retour qu'à l'allier quatre ponts
contre pour cavalier belge voulait
jusqu'à ce que je fasse d'abord il a pas
tord façon c'est très un petit but non
mais je sais ça fait tilt et moi aussi
ça me saoule mais d'un autre côté il
pète on gagne du temps en arnaque une
sur 100 mais non mais c'est sûr je suis
d'accord c'est contre toi cette
franchise j'ai envie de dire c'est un
freeroll au bout d'un moment il joue le
backdoor carne fleuve chaque arrêt ouais
mais ça tombe parfois ça tombe parfois
enfin anthony qui a perdu une partie une
fois comme ça avec tours 5 millions
contre contre roye tour rénovillage
j'imagine non en fait à un moment donné
est tellement de pions il a oublié dans
quel sens aller ses pions c'était dur a
pillé la cuy légal il a fait dame vers
lui ah ouais alors ces règles ont
rapidement la possibilité du coup
illégal
comment grandes chances rendement pardon
des chances de backdoor oui mais
grillades pas cette ressource de la
victoire sur wii les gains
c'est quand même plus limité la gavotte
masse critique est pourquoi tu fais du 3
plus des roses pas pédagogique si je
reviens demain 6 et u 3 puis 9 en fait
il se trouve que c'est du trois plus de
la pac mac ce cas là les arènes c'est 2
3 + 2 dans la finance un plus gros
potentiel j'ai pu moi on tourne ces deux
cas dans la rue de cannes on se bat et
salle de gym et martial alors du coup
c'est d'ailleurs il a sacrifié de
plongée l'autre et j'ai quand même
besoin de sortir son fou mais on voit
qu'il ya des petits problèmes pratiques
pour l'instant à transformer sa piste
plus se bat avec les noirs puis surtout
que maintenant il ya peu de temps à la
pendule donc moins y attend plus a de
chances de s'en sortir quoi
germond alors on est combien on est déjà
102 aujourd'hui on est nombreux je vais
rentrer lien hier on était un peu moins
nombreux mais parce qu'aussi on a
regardé pendant un certain moment le
match n'est pas gage chinarro dit ce qui
était restée assez intéressant donc on
s'est un peu un jardin zen et à 7 ans du
reste intéressant alors monde comme on
écrit chérasse alors shir0x puis bon on
a senti que ça pouvait insulté des mères
à la fin donc nous on était là avec
mathieu moi je suis gêné j'essaie de
venir [ __ ] ma merde aussi facturer ses
lacets ça comble hier j'ai un peu foutu
ma merde dans le match mais l'autoroute
non dans le match une vielle firoud déjà
à ce que firent aucun moment donné quand
il a fait une petite pause quand maxime
on a regagné 3 fayomi 13 0 puis maxime
les trois d'affilée découvrir au jazz
s'est déconnecté pendant trois minutes
avant de nettement le mac pour casser le
rythme et donc je me suis permis
d'écrire pleutre tu n'es pas un athlète
à avoir mis toute ma mère de dans le
tchat
je crois que chaque feu rouge a pas
encore très bien le français
bah il va apprendre le moc l'autre au
moins elle cède en france pour l'instant
vous voulez poser la question n'a pas
encore fait d'effort mathieu mais je
pense que ce doit être à mon avis le
dernier pour apologie du blogueur pascal
mutzig quand tu veux vivre en france de
la ged par les français perçoivent
obligatoire en plus il doit voir
certaines capacités et tu sais les
langues parfois c'est étonnant tu peux
avoir des gens que tu penses mais qui
sont doués en langue et tu pleures des
gens tu dis très intelligents et qui ont
beaucoup de mal à apprendre une langue
c'est un excellent c'est pas un écrivain
comme toi que je vais apprendre ça
les mots les mots c'est quelque chose de
particulier
et tu sais qui est pas 607 fin pas si
simple et pas si compliqué que ça m'est
difficile que qu'elle en a l'air nishida
grect le pion lâche la suite nos pièces
mineurs d'un petit peu du mal à fait je
voudrais essayer de fait si on la voir
le but est en retard dans la course pour
aller à dame
donc je pense que ce sont des changes
des armées a c'est très facile après que
le fou en d5 est quand même bien oui oui
ben avec les doigts en fait il aurait dû
pousser cette foule jusque il fait des
coupes dame mais il progresse pas il est
à cannes c'est pas très grave
dommage même pour les noirs ne pas avoir
chopé à 4 ouais ça augmenter un peu les
chances pratique ce que lapointe
seclinois il a escorté jusqu'à promotion
par les pièces leader ça fait un peu
durable il ya un peu dans le dur mais il
s'est bien battu à bravo à pour avoir
pour bon car elle avec sa pièce de
maurice et a laissé faire avec quelqu'un
qui a valu à m filles étaient très
heureux abbas est peut-être mais c'était
peut-être depuis pat perna
c'est ce que je crois le ciel fm que
j'ai vu à part ces deux derniers
inscrits il ya ya ya poopy poupe aussi
qu'est venu ok même pompier douchez qui
doit donner des cours d'eau qui va pas
jouer longtemps gelé la pop hip hop il
est là il a un coeur de cette cité et la
durée requise et salua le ferait dans la
chambre la ccsa cette patate un jeu bien
qu'un tomber pukki poupe
bah bravo patates à durand grosse perf
bas il est là patate en juniors bientôt
il va devenir patator seniors avec des
pertes comme ça car bon alors ça me
robinson europe inside search ascom est
complètement est tout à fait en tête qui
te fait qui te fait les petits articles
a fait la petite interview de romain
edouard aux scieries pas si petit que ça
d'ailleurs
non
ouais donc là du coup si on réussit à
lancer sa convaincre ça peut être
vraiment franchement ça peut être sympa
autant il ya un an quand on a parlé un
peu au début on n'était pas trop chaud
puis après à force d'en parler aussi que
c'était peut-être moins dur à faire un
peu ce qu'on a pensé la leçon que sur un
grand format ça va être trop compliqué
les gens avec des pleins de physio et
c'est trop bien organisée mais par
contre sûrement juste obtient un socle
17 équipes avec des gens motivés à la je
pense que vous percevez à lyon ça peut
être vraiment cool ça peut être vraiment
cool on va voir je pense que je pense je
pense qu'on va avoir ça me va être chaud
peut-être faire un col avec lui quand
jean-louis very good as et dire venez
terrifié fantastique contasté c'est le
mot qui ponctuera avec les américains
tout le temps est positif il alors très
heureux et on à alfredo la fin de chaque
demande sur la vue un tweet d'un jeune
qui apprend à jouer la seconde amont à
ce que tu peux développer salaires
intéressants autour d'histoires il a
complètement craqué c'est très bizarre
il a pété un plomb quoi il ya eu le clou
aller il a dû dans son cerveau ça du
tilt c'est la dame n'a pas de valeur est
dégage dégage c'est que ce cheval est
beaucoup trop fort j'ai la terre de fous
j'ai des compensations avec six mois il
a vu le tweet de l'événement alors
effectivement bien triste bien triste
nouvelle
ouais ça fera surtout que ça semblait de
loin ça semblait aller mieux mais oui
bah les premières infos c'est que vous
pensez que effectivement son état s'est
amélioré après l'accident les commotions
cérébrales ces salles 1 comme truc ouais
c'est là mon traître tu sais pas ce qui
peut se passer vous regarde pipe ou pan
sur un mode à 7,6 et une poupe ebooks
tout craché la hqe attachante
qu'est ce qui arriva copie poupe la
perdre une partie contre patata julien
et du coup cette nation
sa vie n'est pas d'abord junior bons
joueurs ouais moi je fais aussi sage 4 h
1b tromper de ashes comme sting c'est
pas si mauvais que sans réaliser non y'a
ya pire faites un tour à chis est
toujours fort c'est alpha 0s quoi ouais
c'est ça ce n'est pas du tilt c'est
juste beaucoup trop compliqué pour vous
peut-être que dans le futur serait
l'ouverture à la mode à 4 h 5
ça sera max la plus tard de moi j'avais
vu je crois le tweet de schwarzy froid
que c'est une femme qui me l'envoyer
famille devait arrêter twitter il ya une
semaine ou deux il a écrit oui je ne
serai plus sur twitter bombe et idées
tout en quoi c'est ce que j'avais fait
mon front il en peut plus mais a le truc
c'est que je trouve la difficulté des
réseaux sociaux c'est que parfois tu as
des informations de choses qui se
passent ou quoi mais ça fait des zooms
sur l'info en fait leur les faits divers
en fait ils sont tellement joué avec une
loupe que tu as un fait divers est pas
l'impression que ça se passe partout en
france comme ça alors que c'est juste un
truc à un endroit il ya moyen de ces
grossistes en de chaque action maugrey
fu lei en sueur ou fu lei
finalement voilà vick a cité le h4 c'est
quand même étonnant qu'ils soient un
prix spécial de jouer trop vite
après ça peut être temps d'avoir un mec
en face qui fait n'importe quoi ça peut
te mettre une pression à tous mais la
pression du disque de barrage et les
ridicules du coup et que moi aussi dans
celle d'un che du f3 à f2 en bullet j'ai
pas des cimes des résultats dessus parce
que déjà le mec ce bien plus réfléchir
et juste à tout prix de battre quoi donc
il tresse alors que toi tu joue sans
pression parfois je crois c'est joli ça
ça marche mais je comprends pas surtout
prendre trois points qui le prend 7 mai
du coup hockey lorsque je
bouger la dame aussi avec les blancs
pourquoi il a donné son four casque
obligatoire oui avec les blancs pour
étouffer chemins séparés c'est juste
fois je crois c'est joli mais ce que
c'est utile oui oui je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi rue 9.3 des chiens
maintenant bien vous être contre jeu
pour la partie évidemment tous et
bienvenue à faire juste droite et de ne
pas le choix ou alors il y aura en effet
ton projet c'est bien une pièce de plus
[Musique]
de 4 hebbadj est roi et moi je pense le
connaissant qu'il atteindra même si ce
jeu le code pénal mais elle aime dans
les relais il pouvait pas faire de même
si ce pari il est solide bien jouer
d'approcher son seul coup toute façon
faut s'en débarrasser
je pense que c'est un problème qu'on
n'est pas qu'on n'a pas vu non
on voit tout là bas juste une pièce de
monnaie avec le pion à 5 peut-être
encore activé le ouf
le faux 1,3 fait un bon travail parce
qu'on a du mal à avoir accès à la
colonne h avec les blondes ont caché
très faible 6 h is tombe le pion hd noir
va devenir d'enrochement ou
qu'empruntent 6 a peut être un peu
chiant même très chiant parce que son
fouquet cathy paraissent beau mais a du
mal à les faire jouer les as
artificielles auxquelles ces cinq années
crée une menace
il va vouloir rebondir tête vers 17 -
ouais mais si je passe bien du web tout
à fait oublié
ça fait bien celui-là et après mais bon
alors qu'elle aimait 6
il va peut-être faire un genre de
valentin tu touches tu touches tu
touches à une intéressant mais avec ce
n'est pas si facile avec la borne à une
pièce de plus
hu en deux options comme est en fait les
fous de couler reposer la structure
d'options qui est aligné avec les fous
crée une espèce de blocus
ouvrez le problème c'est qu'on me manque
vraiment de rupture d'options un seul à
disposition que c'était à 4 qui la situe
cour l'a t on ce que tu es assez content
parce qu'en ces 5 pouces et un mail à
mon poste mais dans les faits en fait tu
vas 80 de ce tir ces cas là même avec
notre roi d'autres fous et blizzard
position oui oui on pensait que ça
allait très vite
et finalement il prend comme ça parce
que maintenant des 5 fm
ouais je pense que c'est bizarre cette
fin ça ne paraît pas du tout d'un tram
en plus si je vous ragez 6 derrière hall
a priori c'est le cadeau de trop bons
vieux volets qui a pas l'air dans son
assiette aujourd'hui s'appelle la
première partie pour la regarder
ouais après il est co leader file est
deuxième ok juste en fait quand on le
regarde ça se passe mal l'ubs emploie
points elle a bien joué
le fou qui revient c'est très bien ça
maintenant il a fait le taf devrait
contrôler h 2 maintenant il ya le plus
de contre jour même où il tente de trucs
mais juste parce qu'en fait maintenant
le foie f3 se retrouve en cloud pas
tarie
ah il rattrape en v5 et pas attendre
encore et du coup tu en prends cavaliers
bêtement il ya des rois prend tout
d'avants très puissants sont passés
avant moi de jeu à l'aveuglé bizarre
mais pour pour avoir beaucoup joué
d'arena je peux te dire que les arénas
là ils sont déjà à 30 minutes de jeu tu
as vraiment des absences à l'écouté
assez confiant même si ta grosse absence
dé telecinco de l'absence
ouais mais là les ses shows en fait
parce que le roi des blancs il est plus
il vient juste jouer tomber un peut-être
alors dans la cabine sous l'emprise
d'une secte ivement c'est bien du tout
aimé y à peine les coups c'est ça je
comprenne à l'éperon et même si sa forme
perdre n'a pas cette bataille d'avants
ce peintre qui fait toujours marrer dans
les arénas russie c'est que les gens et
les qualités de cette là où va la cgt
oui non je dévoilais parfois mal si
j'étais absent souvent entre vers la 40e
minute
j'ai du mal à démarrer les dix premières
minutes joue mal après je vois bien
jouer pendant trente quarante minutes et
souvent j'ai une absence et les gens
souvent dans le chat et ils sont là dire
ouais tu t'es chauffe avant mes trucs si
tu t'es chauffe avant tu es fatigué
plutôt sur les dix neuf tu as plus de
pauses pendant mais quand tu fais des
post us est jamais si tu vas pas perdre
le rythme parce que tu en fait tu devais
faire la pause avant les fêtes mais tu
sais pas quand tu vas perdre donc
l'année je sais pas quelles ont fait
faire une pause et franchement moi
personnellement en tout cas je n'arrive
pas à bien jouer pendant deux heures
d'affilée j'ai toujours au moins un
moment d'absence voire même deux bon ça
c'est normal d'avoir un creux alors pour
pippo qu'il veut forcer alors tu peux
ce que je sais pas il va mener son âge
quand a vite voulu acheter des sourires
nouvelle volaille non mais là je pense
qu'il a juste prêt vous y avez vous
prendrez vite il voyage est retourné cet
échec du coup il a le droit d'abandonner
mais je me demande en fait si l'on le
roi belles âmes un satan si quand le roi
il est venu en a sept si t'as pas un fou
de la deux échecs qui traîne cette fois
ci mais en fait cela sachez qu'avec la
mauvaise tour je pense au début n'ont
peut être pas permis aux royals étaient
ravis de leur fallait peut-être le faire
un détour bekkat hockey l'a peut-être
fait qu'il essaie juste de faire père
fait battre au b2 - est tout rond et
surtout quelle question
j'y prends pas du tout à un point des
blues c'était intéressant en tout cas
mais beaucoup d'erreurs a beaucoup de
gaffes
ouais là c'était une partie et aux non
seulement qu'on puisse dire
le point deux joueurs parmi les plus
forts du tournoi jean foule à la fin de
journée outre une poule et pina temps le
site rassemble un beau choc jean foule
qui est deuxième nan quart de point à
châteaubourg qui 76e
j'ai cru il a fait qu'elle prendrait
quatre handicaps dans les causses est
pourtant j'ai dit une fois dans les
vidéos ne fallait pas jouer
pourquoi est ce que nous
[Musique]
si la dame vient des quatre au début si
on fait des quatre comprendra france est
pas bon parce qu'elle se fait passer par
le cavalier oui mais si après cavaliers
f3 cavalli c6 des quatre ans qui prend
qu'elle prend dame france qu'est cette
partie la dame peut plus être chassé à
l'hyper forte ce qu'elle vole beaucoup
de cases elle est en plein coeur de
l'échiquier effectivement elle met la
pression
par exemple sur le g7 des bouquets c'est
interdit pour autant à des petits trous
sur quatre gauche quand même il choisit
elle est sûre cases noires ils sont pas
nationales
il veut attaquer c'est pourquoi comme un
tempo oui oui non en fait c'est
peut-être le meilleur avec ses 4 à
première vue avec six ans que gagne
quand même le tempo parce que tu veux
faire échec et puis la suite sinon
j'aurais pu s'annoncer quatremer layada
m'agace on peut justifier de se
développer très vite ces trois sets ça
serait vraiment bien de réussir à
empêcher les douars de broc est donc
c'est pour ça qu'on prend les cases
blanches damas quatre bien qu'il va se
montrer gourmand poupine à tort
peut-être qu'ils nous écoutent pas à
voir on va déjà une grosse connerie on
va voir si nos suites damas huit agents
funa jean football du rhin j'en fus qui
a craqué j'en fume dans le jura alors
cet accès à des repas pas d'accord la
patate or on va voir s'ils continuent
alors ses exploits pas forcément puisque
l'élan joue à peu près de son classement
je deviens nul ça mais bon la capote
masqué c'est le jour sans ouais faut se
démasquer peut-être c'est ça qu'est
comment être commis autant et je sais
pas moi j'ai toujours mal autant je
passe ma vie est d'avoir moins de temps
que mes adversaires je
mais j'ai remarqué que sur 30 secondes
et une minute et quelques confondues je
sais pas en fait j'ai pas pourquoi après
je lui explique aussi compte du stream
super doux tendre la joue
ouais ouais causalité alors cette
position est intéressante
j'ai quatre barré assez bizarre ça va
permettre aux blancs kelly des thèmes
poudre développement et stouff qui nous
laisse bien écouter à bientôt
pas de concours stouff après une bonne
pointe de vitesse quand même en beats
oui à la fin mclaren accès nomade son
site web des lois je suis très chiant
quand il me reste 30 secondes et que je
commence à bouger vite c'est déjà le cas
en partie réelle est battu natsu lava
une fois comme ça hein regretté nenad il
y avait dix minutes contre une minute 15
une position qui doit être à plus 1 50 e
+2 l'adulte et je les écoeurer quoi je
crois que j'ai joué les seules coupes en
hyper longtemps et après il s'est
retrouvé avec peut-être 40 secondes
contre une minute 20 m et sa santé
critique t parce que le effet seule
défense la défense seule défense pendant
longtemps et sans compter dans la partie
n'a pas beaucoup de temps de temps une
espèce de deux d'état second un peu
ouais ça se passe bien tu trouve les
bons coûteux dans la zone est du coup
quand en face c'est chiant sur richie et
c'est frustrant parce que tu attendes
jeudi mais qui va craquer ouais et puis
tu craques pas et puis après le truc
c'est que peut-être quand il y avait une
20 contre 40 secondes c'était déjà égale
gens étaient sortis et du grand fayt
psychologiquement moi je me dis je vais
continuer à jouer vite je vais continuer
à tout trouvé puis lui en fait ils
démoralisant quoi as tu sais que le
moins tourné en sont nous sentons tous
partis il ya des moments des devoirs
suis pressé il faudrait qu on accepte de
juste se contenter de la nulle par
exemple parce que ça tourne de dire ok
maintenant c'est bon c'est parti ou le
fait pas ou est-ce dans notre impression
2,30 dominé on veut gagner et souvent
jeudi par perdre dans ces cas là c'est
dur de savoir qu'on tentait de l'année
le comte a dominé toute la partie alors
une option de plus pour les blancs plus
ciel fois je suis content bien dominé
mais il veut essayer de récupérer 5
reste qu'avec les blancs et joue aux six
auxquelles elles sont pas naturellement
et avec les noirs sont directs et
réussissent mais quand même moins bien
ainsi claire des prises on est en train
d de wet août pour ces métaux 6 pour
faire des cavaliers b45 un jour tu
récupères russie s'apprêtait à duper 3
le courage c'est bien une faiblesse
alors est souvent un atout les pièces
blanches en fait assez bien placées
elles ont un peu de mal à se coordonner
maintenant pour trouver quelque chose de
concret avec les noirs de cet incident
dont plus peut-être b5 bi 4 j'aime bien
tu fais jouer et on fout ouais mais tu
t'en vois n'a pas énormément d'autres
plans à disposition faut 5 spykr as tu
rentres en béotie way 5 mètres pour
forcer des deux c'est plutôt pas mal
même je me tâte un junior même temps pas
tard je n'en ai que je le connais
beaucoup à y est chaud aujourd'hui on a
compris qu'il était très chaude et alors
des menaces qui est mariée au placement
netapp science pas trop comment ça se
dit tiens 9 sur 9 et que celles ci sont
elles qui en train de marcher sur l'eau
près faut faire gaffe enfin toujours
dans ses arénas tu sais pas vraiment
contre qu'ils ont joué il a pu jouer que
des jeux un moment donné quand deux mecs
plus fort il se fait stopper les forts
ils peuvent vraiment remonté quoi bon
bah moi jusqu où il tiendra bien
maintenant il a fait la moitié il à la
mi temps c'est la seule victoire pour
lui on est à mi tournoi là on a mis
tournoi axel de man is the man
j'ai envie de te dire et la petite main
bitstream il a étudié les il a la classe
il a la classe sur du coup tu le soutien
contrebas date un junior est
complètement voilà la petite marque
quand même ça fait la diff non moi je
donne tu côté de patates un gyan rennes
poursuit sa patate on avatar eye cherry
est choyé cheru si tu veux te tapes a
pas de petites mains bitstream toi mon
pseudo est non moi j'ai mal j'ai mal je
m'en fous toi et tu serais intéressé par
une main bitstream ou pas pour l'avoir
mais pour la refiler à des gens je
garderai ma photo c'est plus sérieux
m je peux trouver le truc je t'aime et
donc chaque match et a besoin d'un peu
de classe un pesant un peu tendu classe
sur votre profil chez scott est chargé d
avatar personnalisé bitstream au moins
tu les reconnais que c'est qu'ils ont de
faire des écossaises et les scandinaves
et des scandinaves comme elle est pas
mal et c'est bien réussi j'en suis
tellement heureux de cette mare en fait
voilà on m'attend et les classes
il m'a coûté très cher en plus ceci cela
aide vraiment sans déconner c'est
vraiment un gars pro qui lave qui l'a
fait et c'est un gars qui a travaillé
pour pour des marques pour des pour des
grandes marques en vrai entre guillemets
mais franchement tu vois la différence
entre un truc prod un mec vraiment pro
est un gars
juste designers qui fait qu'en fait tu
vois dans le cahier des charges est que
ce soit un truc simple sur un truc qui
puisse se déclarer que décliner
facilement qu'ils soient bien sûr un
t-shirt si on fait des produits dérivés
ou quoi et en fait c'est où je le gagne
il a vraiment respecté le cahier des
charges à fond mais la grille était là
puisqu'il est joli succès des poèmes
souvent le problème de gens de logo
coisy y en a trop fait pas y'a un truc
oui la pâte égalisé 4-4
c'est en fait la chine c'était plus
facile à bouger dans l'absolu que oui
bon ok là dans les deux cas il doit être
cailloux la carte aya cavaliers des six
je me suis un peu emballé je pense que
ça doit être nul j'en remets à mais les
deux peuvent gagner parce que ces genres
en pratique c'est combien de gens les
finales de cavaillé c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus dur je trouve mais en pratique à
calculer ouais ça horrible parce que la
pièce a une telle mon petit porte et que
déjà moins fou tu sais que tu contrôles
la diagonale auquel cavaliers c'est très
compliqué est toujours un un rebond un
soda pas prévu un truc je suis en deux
versions pour attention qu'avec 4 alors
à tarbes ou alors en fait vous veut de
tout passer diverses assala très mauvais
je pense que c'est une cata oui et puis
surtout notre cavalerie fait rien et
vous quelle quelle était l'idée de tenir
à trois par contre à la la il est là il
est en train de se la faire là naïf non
mais les banquiers il peut la sauver
j'amène je pense pas forcément que ça
gagne 1,6 pour le dow ouais mais
clairement tu préfère avoir la même avec
le pur h allawi non mais toute façon est
là bas c'était plutôt 8 chu pour le gain
mais là c'est de bien jouer de pavot
gère 4
mais à des cavaliers de aussi à qui il
faut faire gaffe
quel est des deux qui a eu quatre situe
environ à 3 ans revient en d2 - domine
quand même bouclard normalement on va
aller chercher juste eu fait roi des
trois ici qu'à valider cinq pays france
et 4 nuls
ah ouais le carrier du mauvais côté non
mais y aller prendre et 6 3 et 4 oui y'a
pas moyen de cavaliers ils soient ils
protègent par derrière et là il n'y
arrive pas alors maintenant d'être
cavaliers des cinq rois trois quais ces
trois sur moi et sur roy b 2 à 4 4
ouais sagan qui est des cinq essais avec
a été 5 3 et 4 mais on peut analyser
c'est intéressant tout ce qui peut bien
d'autres encore étaient hyper
intéressante la position oui ben ali
c'est un peu l'idée de la fin alors roy
b4 ça gagne à cause de cavaliers des
cinq donc sur what's on expliqué vanier
c3 et du coup là dessus et sur roy c4 le
coup moi la question posée par un f4 à
et maintenant il va toucher c'est
l'avenir en scène par détroit aux
parents eux deux est en fait le cavalier
juste enlevé derrière parce que du coup
il est tabou si on le mange le roi sort
du quart et du cloud donc le pion court
trop vite on peut plus jamais le
rattraper et donc il fallait faire mais
ça c'est que ça peut être un super
exercice pour des courants parce que en
soit c'est un super exo je suis en train
de faire le scream voie la plus sûre
fans précis et souvent beaucoup plus
facile avec un fou de gagner ce genre de
post aucun canal + que lecavalier
ils courent pas très vite
donc il a du mal à revenir dans la zone
on a besoin de lui alors que le fourbe
injuste slalom d'agde à l'autre donc
c'est céline et mes affaires à une
position tu vois pas ce qui est bien
c'est que du coup là ça fait pas moins
de position tu pourrais mettre en oeuvre
dans les problèmes
ah ouais carrément c'est un vrai
problème intéressant pédagogique et très
très bien mais c'est ça qui est beau
dans les échecs je trouve aussi c'est
que tu peux trouver vraiment de la
beauté à beaucoup de situations tu vas
tu parles et ont joué à football manager
hier avec fabu age of employeur ou tous
ces jeux là et je trouve que les échecs
ont un esthétisme que tous ces jeunes
ont pas en réalité car mon sac par un
besoin
même le poker un toit qui a beaucoup
joué il n'y a pas un enjeu non pas du
tout pas du tout parce que il ya quand
même la part aléatoire qui donne un
charme et de banca beauté ne pas pas
quelque chose on fait deux purs nous
échec
oui aux échecs la position soit les
gagnants soit les parfums pour trouver
une position commune et tuez nous il ya
un problème l'exercice au poker nous
parce qu'il ya deux facteurs aléatoires
c'est ça qui aimait les échecs c'est
pour ça que je me dis que c'est
peut-être même plus un arc un sport ou
quoi que ce soit parce que ses parents
ce côté beauté quoi ouais mais
l'harmonie sont harmonisés harmoniser
ses pièces et faire les faire danser
ensemble sur l'échiquier c'est ce qu'on
recherche
ouais c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un
jeu qui est beau et c'est ça qui est ça
qui est cool nature a une position une
jolie position par hasard alors
la mine gaby ou à munich à 300 points de
plus
ça donne quoi la position la manger deux
pions viager trois quarts en l'air et
bien d'un g 4 du coût auquel les gammes
du contrôle jeu sur cases noires les
foudres couleurs opposées favorise un
peu quand même les attaques
la dame g4 chez les dames les bergers
trois geeks et 6 gagne 1,8
il prend tous là du coup il simplifie le
travail et l'abandonnent moi parce
qu'enfin on pratique s'était pas perdue
ou même avec 2 qui on demande dans le
tournoi alors de metz qui souffrent
c'est pas le meilleur des belles-soeurs
surtout sur internet
attendu qu'on va pouvoir peut-être
choper une partie qui commence de thé
non j'ai coupé mon chèque était quand
même plusieurs fois champion de france
chez les jeunes
c'est un pouvoir des mots nax wayne
champion de france je suis ni un ouais
ouais donc ça envoie quand même voilà ça
envoie non plus un philosophe doux pour
toi le peu que le supporter et
philosophe en plus il est prof de philo
au bac c'est pas beau métier d'homme
était très intéressant je passe sur un
peu à des chaînes de philo sur youtube
mais si tu lis un peu des livres de
philo je peux bien peu des choses après
regardé par contre sur youtube pas
vraiment un drame où c'est intéressant à
la philosophie apl bl bs unique album
était professeur ouais c'est un beau
métier c'est trop de demandes sur mon
gant par super j'imagine que bien celle
avantage c'est pour ça que quand on nous
demandait je le répète sa part
comprennent bien ce sera quand on dit
fait lui en système suisse et mieux et
où il ya des avantages mais le gros
inconvénient c'est que les joueurs qui
veulent passer comme ça jouer deux
parties ou même comme poopy poupe qui
est maître fils de quoi ils pourraient
pas le faire au système suisse pays bas
ça permet de rentrer et de sortir
viendrait pas mal de longues secondes au
match oui google les arènes au plus de
charme sa part et d'enchaîner les
parties en plus du coup tu t'en vas pas
attendre que tout le monde finisse tu
peux être à celle où parfois frustrant
surtout en trois plus de kant avait
également d'autres pas
roy tour contre roye tour qui se joue
pendant cinquante coups c'est
insupportable surtout que ça nous est
déjà arrivé sur ce score alors
maintenant ils ont ils font un truc qui
s'étonnent ils s'étalent l'annulent
league lille mais a beaucoup de
cinquante couples qui avait promis sur
l'état a été accusé il ya des gars et y
jouer pendant 100 kw il faisait exprès
de pas demandé la nulle j'avais vu dans
détaille-t-elle du coup ça faisait rage
et balma cas par exemple ou à juste
titre à la menace et à dernier à ce
genre de truc tout con tre pour me payer
un coût mignon cas et des cinq jeux
précités bon c'était mignon est l'allié
des 5
il faut essayer d'être fort sur
quasiment sont ensuite restés bons amis
c'était mignon oui on aime bien sa
cuisse de cavaliers sur les sicilienne
notamment les dessins que c'est un
classique
les trois qui dit dommage faire et ce
que tu rends service à dire plus le coup
goethe autant j'ai eu droit qu'à un
tournant par semaine alors pourquoi
tarde à 15 fois par semaine que une
règle pas rentable pour un confinement
très stricte
je ne sais pas je pense qu'il a le droit
que parce qu'il n'est pas diamant quoi
mais là c'est vraiment ouvert à tout le
monde c'est pas un tournoi
les limitations d'un point de vue
réglementaire comme la lui il peut jouer
autant qu'il veut ce genre de tournoi
c'est peut-être juste quelque chose du
personnel c'est pas dans la tête la
réponse alors il ya un flash 4 qui dans
nos poubelles ou à grains tf2 derrière
honorum king plus ou même un petit
avantage pour les noirs craignent pas
grande chose
ben voilà même si ce toit fluide non me
contredis on peut toujours dire que les
règles très mental et les règles
maritale bas schéma qui suit on pense de
moi ça va ça va bien se passer
d'ailleurs j'attends mais je vais
peut-être pas maître yoda mais je pense
je pensais pas que je pense que tu
pensais pas que j'avais le droit de
jouer de référence par rapport à maître
yoda aux mecs dont il met le hockey le
petit m yoyo ce qui dans une vidéo jeux
tu pensais pas que j'allais dire ces
choses là tu pensais que ce serait tabou
mais lance pas tabou bref je vois je
suppose
tu vois m lioret tu vois qui sait oui le
haricot vert touche à tout ça vous plaît
maxime maxime donc bien rentré en vous
contant way s'est exprimé d'ailleurs sur
le parce que je suis vidé rajab offre
d'achat ou par l'est certainement
plusieurs fois a envie d'être réintégrée
au tournant des candidats et donc maxime
huot évidemment ils pensent que c'est
absolument pas possible envisageable
chacun chacun défend son son escalope de
poulet dans le cas de maxime monsieur te
dire quand il rentrait à pareil quand il
est arrivé
un jour après m'envoyer une photo sur
facebook afin d'acheter du plan il m'a
dit je reprends la diète
du coup il est un athlète clairement
mais là ils approuvaient l'a prouvé à m
très bientôt la donne un petit coup
n'est pas grosse partie ouais ouais ben
leber victoire avec contre l'epo qui le
veut qu'il place qui le place bien dans
le tournoi je pense qu'elle est hyper
important de salon plus avant la pause
et où avant la mi-temps voit jean
laprise si reprise il ya dans ces
conditions et en est moins sûr
ce sera quand même difficile de ce qui
va doubler les droits contre caruana
eding bas les fantômes de yekaterinburg
[Musique]
autant là j'étais assez confiant on
l'état actuel de forme pendant le
tournoi et deux joueurs mais qui sait où
ça reprendra elle sera la condition
ouais moi ce qui me fait ce qu'il fait
d'autant plus peur c'est de me dire à
quel moment caisse et 4d de la nôtre à
quel moment va vraiment avoir le droit
de reprendre les compétitions
internationales
là ce moment impossible de faire de
pronostic
tu prends des deux jambes et deux ans 8
4 4 mais typique où ces gens là position
on se rend compte à quel point le canal
vous fortin fou dans ces finales même
pas 24
c'est sûr que c'est gagnant mais a
laissé un peu chiant franchement c'est
sûr ça doit le gagner mais tu peux
scoring tu peux même la perdre
ok maintenant c'est clairement la bonne
approche s'il essaye de faire la course
tout de suite bas il peut sellal c'est
le cas il peut la perdre j'ai par contre
qu'il fasse gaffe de passes faire rocher
par le roi de l'autre côté
ouais mais ça je trouve que c'est une
erreur bon ouais je sais pas mais
j'aurais quand même c'est d'avancer
leurs pions même affaire 500 m 2 de
l'unama
c'est pas faux c'était de précipiter la
avec les noirs mais quoique 6 et 7 nuls
maintenant cavalier 18 férois g6 et
orale et d'options qui se convainc
mangeable et tu pourras attend ouais là
je pense que c est complètement nulle
maintenant à bien jouer ou un second
album alors attends faut faire des cas à
c'est bien joué mais je pense pas que ça
l'a sauvé non je pensais quand même
parce que c'est trop loin de toute façon
c'était très qui met beaucoup justement
je pas un cavalier voilà maintenant tu
reviens là la patente 5 a laissé trois
monts gb 4
du coup beau sauvetage que de lui avec
les clubs et les katas temps et une
fille se passe plus rien 3 tu passé
contre canal y est ça va évidemment il a
raison
ça on ne peut pas un peut pas ramener le
roi pour soutenir notre pions h que lang
clairement vraiment envie de faire
brasser si celle ci sera bcp 5 histoire
d'être le plus après le possible quoi
y'a rien de tout cela hier aucun plagiat
pas nous on ne peut pas tromper avec les
banques tu fais juste 3 je crois moi
j'ai trois ans après avoir avancé des
pions non c'est parfait ça du maintien
qui arrive sur la moitié de cet aréna
m6 est en tête un petit point un jour
créer la surprise
arts et métiers il a il a bloqué à une
étape une étape il a dû jouer des plus
forts c'est bobby fischer 002 sait
aujourd'hui qui est devant c'est bon
mais n'a pu voir que c'est vraiment pas
fini avant la dernière partie s'est
passé plein de rebondissements déjà dans
les années précédentes
dommage qu'ils étaient les deuxièmes il
à perdre elle a mal de temps en plus tu
as c'est parti on est tous les ans on
dénombrait tiens on a un nouveau maître
fide qu'on n'a pas encore vu mr lose
lose
tu connais non j'ai déjà du blitz écoute
famille samedi un truc mais je sais pas
qui c'est un nouveau venu chez grand
favori la whey après faut se méfier
patates en junior a et crée la surprise
personne dans le tchad allégeant les
gens jouent aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de
plus de joueurs on a moins de personnes
dans le chat qui hier on a plus de gens
dans l'arena
donc j'ai l'impression qu'il ya quand
même un lien de cause à effet entre le
nombre de participants à l'arena et le
nombre de personnes dans le chatt sept
jours de d'animer le chat toujours c'est
pas faux mais 140 c'est bien c'est un
peu injuste
tout est parti c'est pas mal 140 watts
alors 8 tu vois la tour à des problèmes
est ce que j j va noir c'est possible
que ça ne change rien que les blancs la
luge et pas deux fois mysterious pour
perdre pour perdre des mensongères et
des monarques se dévoile à ce qu'il ya
probablement pas réussir à gagner mais
il a perdu de temps c'est quand même
ouais mais bon ils sont forts en face à
8h02 qui échoueront sur 11
maugrée fallen qui aujourd'hui un peu
moins en forme j'ai le droit pas inquiet
j'ai le droit aujourd'hui les îles
échoué hier il était était fin fond de
classement
c'est beaucoup de parties ouais il est
dans la stratégie ce que ce que
j'appelle la stratégie décalée quoi août
abandonne vite contre les fortes
attentes quelque chose tu abandonnes
vite et essaye de maths cg faible cette
stratégie décalée
j'ai marqué cette stratégie où tu peux
en gros tu dis soit je finis vraiment
mal soit je finis bien quoi c'est tu
tentes tu t'en flot de tableau en jouant
en jouant un truc complètement décalé
après le problème c'est comme tu donnes
vite les points ou for abba l'effort du
quiz ils vont s'échapper mais il
s'échappe d'autant plus mais bon tu te
dis c'est pas grave tu espères jouer
d'efforts qui mettront pas de points et
de ses paiements par you wanna kawaii sa
mère stratégie
oui bah tu sais que tu vas perdre et
j'ai systématiquement quand tu perds pas
de temps l'action b brooke est dans ses
arènes j'aime bien jouer contre d'effort
vous faites pas faire juste faire un
parti je vise pas forcément le plus de
points possible ahi c'est malin avec
évidemment petits pièges de fourchettes
sont provoquions donc qui va juste jouer
j'ai cinq ans suite à un moment donné
peut-être pas tous avec un trentenaire
il aura un pion passé
j'en reste quand même très puissant mais
à 4 pas facile à défendre qu'attaquer de
ma partie chiche et quand même à la 1000
plus de 1000 points - là les noirs à
l'estonien il résiste même très bien
très très loin de crédit que l'on est
pas pour être ridicule givet 69-69 en
pseudo donc du 10/01 malin et leurs
cavaliers c5
sûrement mais bon finalement je rouges
et 5
il y aura du f si ceux-ci pas si clair
c'est pas si clair que les pions blonde
pourquoi une touche assez faible pour un
simple pourquoi pas chasse lecavalier il
va prendre quatre les cantalous sur la
tour d2 c'est pas mal pour un simple
revenez en v3 revenir en a quatre
la nature prend là nul debout sur la
table quelque chose dans cette partie
majeure de fait une amortie par presque
g5 intermédiaire du coup est possible
assure il va prendre direct la tour la
hiérarchie ce qui sera en l'air un jour
tous les pions blancs se retrouveraient
faible donc c'est pas si grave
nice toulouse en sueur ouais c'est la
pression la pression de direct ouais
ouais c'est pas c'est pas du tout sûr
qu'ils l'emportent dans cette partie il
reste une minute alors que peut-être il
faut autre chose en même temps en tout
cas je suis très longtemps sur ce coup
c'est possible d'allier le b3 et pas
trop de documents objets simples
eliseu et cinq aides que 5 5 pas idiot
peut-être perdre autant à elio non plus
voilà ça pour vous venir en deux trois
villes et maître fide en sueur dans ce
tournoi sur place à l'élite 1 c'est pas
un tournoi facile hein jeudi retour des
4 mai savons pas grand chose et pas bête
qui me donnait son fou ou pas d'ailleurs
contre le canadien je sais pas il veut
jouer tout au 2e rang à 2 227
idem à un serrage 6,3 g satin faroy
progressiste upa ranger cet événement
sont mieux ben ouais puis à g4 ont l'air
aussi genre ouais moi aussi je pensais
juste bien et je reviens quand même en
g7 n'en fout aussi ils assistent au
match à 7-6 1 3 pas se prendre du tour à
8b 5 bien joué la crème du fou processus
qui traîne mais j'ai quatre peut-être
oui de reims après malheureusement ça
qui perd les deux pions là dommage je
n'attends pas du tout alors tour sévit
toi 17,1 peut être le seul coup dans
cette tour c'est cette cloud la boîte à
clous
cavalier ou six là c'est la course n'en
voyais à fond mais il est mieux comme
mec le nombre ils ont qu'à tout le moins
il est blond avec le nom il faut que je
fous des 5 mai ses cadres etc au plus
vite et les gens lisent beaucoup plus
fort même s'ils viennent de ne plus être
liée 2 alors est ce qu'il attend de
faire voir s'en fout des cinq noms il
pourrait passer pour un temps c'est vrai
qu'ils aient passage de fou 17 je pense
ouais alors il parle avec son bois venir
dieu x 6 x f1 fou j'ai deux heures à
faire c'est la grosse partie là si les
blancs étaient en voulu vraiment jouer
la gagne
ils vont la perdre et ils ont la paire
france avait plutôt ramèneront à f2 et
défendre avec les blancs et que l'acte v
veut pour la nuit
c'est la sensation non je vais vous
faire acheter et rend le port de jijel à
la hausse game on a on a vu on a vu la
plus grosse surprise des arénas en
direct avec nulle 1100 points de mort
avec les noirs et a sorti la partie 1 il
a fait une passe il n'a pas tremblé
impressionnant il a joué vite afin
d'assumer son intuition
[Musique]
ouais il a été il a il a été très bon et
il n'y a pas de grue du tout les gars
parce qu'il ya eu des gaffes et tous
deux
deux côtés regarder on avait un peu leur
dit à certains moments et il a raté la
qualité en 1 ils ont raté plus les deux
des trucs donc c'était juste une partie
normale ou abbas s'est bien passé la
vente un soupçon possible il a juste
vous méritez du coup peut-être que notre
nouvel ami à maître fide ou battu le
noir est reparti serre le jeu
et ouais c'est peut-être un peu trop
facile
après pour dire quand tu es nouveau sur
thiès comme où t'as pas l'habitude de
jouer contre des mecs comme ça tu peux
être très surpris du niveau des gares
400 fait tu peux penser que c'est comme
des 14 clubs et les jouets vraiment
facile il faut plutôt aller jouer comme
des 750 10 700 sont plutôt que de bonnes
parties comme ouais ouais ils sont plus
forts que ce qui me paraît donc que le
que leurs lots le suggère donc il faut
il faut être très vigilent rouleur là
par contre tu arthur du 505 c'était une
patrie qui nous lie à la gaffe a dit
qu'il avait battu en 2000 alors qu'il a
que 1200 que c'est aussi une très très
bonne paire de cailloux la whey et
barbarian séverac est en train de
s'envoler au ac ils rasent parce que là
il a le hilal eux il a le strict il
vient de gagner une partie rapide sur un
bond de dames
alors attention parce que julien je
venais ce qui là encore 100% qu'il a
joué au moins une partie non sur 14
bobby fischer et la boue sur le 12 mai
il a perdu il a perdu la partie du doubs
sur douze avions sur 11
du coup tout est possible en corse un
point et reste un gros quart d'heure
ouais c'est encore jouable mais ça passe
par une défaite de parts par ailleurs
c'est ma dans cette partie où au moins
il n'eut alors dans cette partie où dans
la suivante
ben ouais ouais tout cas il faut une
défaite deux fois encore mais ça
s'arrête là
il a passé deux parties aussi jose à
paris meaux ça c'est
pour moi c'est ça qui est fun en fait
oui oui mais déjà arrivé parfois du coup
de jouer contre des mecs tu vois 2006
dans les arénas mais qui joue foule
théorie est donc que tu es battre
facilement et est parfois je vais contre
des mecs à 10 900 qui sont des systèmes
de l'undd avec les blancs ultra solide
qui abandonne pas et met longtemps à
battre c'est pas forcément les joueurs
les plus faibles et ouais ça peut
arriver que ça tombe que oui le mec va
jouer ultra solide avec les blancs il
m'a tout bétonner ta faute tu vois je
prendre si l'une pour gagner la partie
avec les noirs c'est un rival à gagner
ouais alors que tu aurais pu jouer
contre un autre mec forte qui a besoin
de gagner aussi et qui va jouer une
partie un peu enflammé qui va se
terminer très vite parfois c'est d'aller
plus vite aussi clairement mais fausse
même chaîne ça c'est pas les voir les
plus faibles qui te permettent de ça
dépend de la situation dans le tournoi
sur pareil là tu vois un truc un peu
5-fu proche 7 et kelly et 5,25 moi
j'aurais passé un petit moment à
regarder mais c'est clairement en baisse
1 que clairement l'idée principale est
siens d'ouvrir les gonades du fond blanc
ou chage le principal défenseur du roi
noir savoir le canadien m6 du coup avoir
beaucoup une pièce calme orienté sur le
rock indé sont pas très bon pour les
marges 36,6 alors contre total et
pourtant carré le mil de soyaux utilise
un ordi dans l'aréna écoute moi j'ai vu
quatre parties depuis le prix séjour de
boer bancal j'ai toujours pas vu gagner
une partie et wind on l'a vu jaune
on en a commenté une là c'est oui ou non
mais c'est évident qu'il ya des mots car
aucun soupçon possible ou que grand
trotteur doit calmer ses ardeurs
accusatrice oui mais il faut arrêter de
voir de la triche par toi
si quelqu un tri j'ai vraiment tout cas
sur toutes les parties après sur une
partie ne peut jamais savoir on les voit
pas tout mais aussi quelqu'un sur toutes
les parties et 12 ans normalement ils
seraient censés être devant et pourquoi
tous les jours on voit les mêmes mecs à
2000 2003 dans les premières places
donc il semble quand même que dans ses
arénas sites riches il ya une semaine
huit ans et 98 37 lots de précision il
veut rien dire c'est à dire que 20 selon
la partie
il a du sens où l'on pousse méfiait
sutton pression après que ce qui est
étriquée aux associations une partie des
achats avait tellement à dire tout le
temps sur le chat que tout le monde
triche et on voit pas les pseudos que
vous dites dans les premières places
donc encore que la série qui l'a 7 sûr
on savait qu'ils avaient beaucoup de
partis tout d'un coup bon peut-être que
il se trouve que je ne sais pas mais bon
ouais si jamais c'est le cas c'est
malheureux ça peut vous arriver une fois
de temps en temps si on passe à la
partie suivante mais station la gamme
des des bonnes choses comme ça il ya des
trucs qui sont mises en place pour
essayer de lutter contre ça est ce que
c'est ce que je veux surtout dire c'est
que si on lit le chat on aurait
l'impression que 95% du tournoi triche
alors que c'est à quoi là un joueur sur
quelque partie mais c'est pas clairement
[Musique]
après vous pouvez toujours vous pouvez
toujours envoyer un signalement pour pis
si ça l'est déjà commencé par regarder
vous un peu avec l'ordi hermès n'aura
pas valeur de vérité absolue
et si vraiment vous avez destruction va
envoyer un signal ou le joueur s'il a
rien fait deux fois samedi sera leur a
pas de problème là ça se passe pas très
bien pour écharpe
on va peut-être retourner voir du coup
la tête du classement qui jusque là d'un
mariage julien mais vraiment les points
mais les points il enchaîne deux parties
le géant julien suis de pas très loin là
deux victoires et douze minutes c'est
encore faisable pour julien et je ne
ressens pas la dernière par exemple et
comme dit fonds qui a pas d'enjeu un
particulier c'est pour se faire plaisir
donc quel est l'intérêt de tricher mais
bien sûr il ya les multi comptes après
enfin moi j'aurais tellement rien à
faire en fait que oui moi hier je suis
tombé sur une heure un truc qui
trichaient bois tu passes à la partition
du coup ça fait ça nous arrive tous nous
arrivent tous à tandis que ta voix est
un peu plus forte que la mienne j'ai un
peu baissé
ok ouais ouais non ça moi ça m'arrive
est pas vrai pas plus tard qu'hier sur
une partie ça arrive ça arrive une fois
tous les cinq ans tous en partie oui
c'est dans cet endroit
nous on passe un filon c'est pas grave
le mec a triché bah bravo à lui il est
heureux comme ça tombe bien alors là
c'est dommage pour julien que barbare
ailleurs que bruno ait raté cac et prend
des deux camps c'est loin c'est la
grosse gaffe de bahreïn comme tu as par
marion qui arrive quand même quand tu
diack que les mecs vois pas qui est tout
à fait ça il parlera aussi de la russie
dans ce que c'était quand même une pièce
en et du coup ça aurait été très
compliqué à remonter mais il est pas
tirés d'affaires pour autant et encore
parce que voilà 7 foot couleurs opposées
c'est assez évident que le fou blancs
des noirs dominent complètement il
faudra d'abord un très beau vous autres
un très mauvais vous et si les noirs ou
jamais intérêt en mangeant des cartes
puisque ça pour ouvrir un petit peu le
foot et de quelle que soit d'ailleurs la
diagonale qui s'ouvre pour lui
instant il est complètement 2010 faut
juste un gros un gros coup derrière
c'est un choix
le plomb est en train de
voilà c'est nécessaire et devait essayer
de le recycler d'en faire quelque chose
juste je coupe mes julien qui a gagné
pendant ce temps sa partie donc il
revient à 48 ses shows barion il est
vraiment pas gagner celle-là il a
éléments bien ouais la dame qui peut
venir à tout moment si cela tours en c1
et c'est plutôt le fougueux 4 qui est
dominant fef six tours hk sera ok tu
passeras d'un projet six tours à lui 2
bat ouais il suffit de bouger la toux 27
du coup y'a pas de menace c'est pas faux
mais tu peux le tenter bien sûr mais bon
dams et ses retours séance arrive plus
vite donc la plus vite et où même tour
ces deux tounes g2 ça peut mais il faut
faire attention là je crains le twh 4 où
ces deux dames projet si ce lot
je vois que vous prend enfin déjà arrivé
je vais même pas regardé
en attendant wet feet mais vous forcez
d'ailleurs c'est pas si en fait c'est
pas clair parce que sur ya pas un tour
pour achètes ton point à celle d'un
prochaine ce qu'adam g 2 oui c'est pas
si clair il faut qu'il voie royale fit
aussi ça peut être dur à son niveau mais
bon après une amende comme ça tempo
c'est qu'ils émanent de la gamme un peu
de temps voilà les matins la bulle
marque du coup c'est le seul coup ses
forces celles auxquelles assez chaud
puisque tarif 6 euros 1,8 alors que ces
choix sinon tu te fais ma télé que les
blancs tour à 103 je sais tu sais rien
allez je vois pas comment continuer à
attaquer mais blizzard nous mêmes ces
normes ne sauve pas peut-être fait roi
premier fin du coup mais c'est la vie
rires tu tentes encore le piège qui on
prend tour à 8,7 toujours matt tu vas te
faire mater d'un machin c'est un oui non
clairement mais j'ai peut-être faut
tenter 1 et la 2 minutes pour le coup là
lassant moment où prendre tout son temps
parce que c'est un peu décisif
ouais après c'est bête parce qu'il a
voulu faire une stratégie en jouant vite
pour que la partie se finisse vite et
maintenant comme tu obligé de remonter
ça aussi tu joues contre un joueur fait
mach influent la partie elle va être
très longue mais j'ai pris à son propre
piège
elle est pris à son propre piège parce
que tu n'oses pas la donne et a quand
même 700 points ou de plus donc t'as pas
envie d'en faire cadeau
il propose nul ça assez pleutres mais ça
va être bien joué mais la ville rachète
ça fait mal
acheter un monde où bruno qui se laisse
pas compter bien joué suite
on m'appelait pour très bon réflexe de
grenouilles simplifier c'est l'abandon
et grosse gueule de bruno
qu'ils arrêtent et du comment c'est
julien qui a acquis un peu le destin
allait qui gagne en plus sa partie
contre gj vkii avait battu un joueur
aussi fort qu'on venait de voir
donc c'est julien maintenant qu'il ya le
qui a guidé par marianne assez dommage
quand même d'avoir voulu jouer trop vite
tu vois c'est un peu le truc que je dise
en aréna compter devant tu peux gérer
était pas obligé de de jouer vite comme
il l'a fait quoi donc rarement là on me
demande ce que bagdad a encore une fois
qu'un 1200 cette victoire sur bakou
enfermé c'est possible c'est peu moins
ça rend le système voilà ce que dit
calme là que 1200 il va jouer un mille 1
mil 101 milles 4 0 c'est pas un suisse
ou des thugs active est à parier contre
un des leaders et ainsi de suite
d'ailleurs bruno bon je vais regarder
mais franchement les gars c'est
impressionnant de en fait il a son
meilleur classement les gars il a fait
200 partis sur le site fin faut arrêter
de voir en plus cela n'a vu la patrie
négation d'un coup dans cette partie oui
il a raté une pièce en est la plus plus
set il n'a pas vu là pour le coup ne
pensent qu'à l'ordinateur il va pas
cavalier prof où tout peut pas avoir des
soupçons soir avec un bal fou en deux
temps c'est juste mais disons que j'ai
appris à jouer des coups logique et puis
ces prix-là pranger si cela pas mesdames
angers 6
enfin les jantes les gens font de
blocage sont sourds banques à l an passé
comme si fait sans parti il ya une
partie qui a peut être fait un blocage
aussi parce que tu as perdu 10 points
elo sur pias coop enfin je sais pas au
bout d'un moment soit vous aimez les
échecs soit j'ai du mal à comprendre en
fait ouais on va la diviser surtout en
plus de la situation actuelle réclame
des choses bien plus c'est quand même
anecdotique à l'échelle d'une vie et à
une chance sur cent quarante de jouer
dans le tournoi chaque parti qui vais
pas leur dire à chaque fois ça
représente une partie sur 300 quoi et tu
fais un signalement ont fait le giro
bout d'un moment ça me paraît juste fou
en fait ouais fait c'est justement on
leur accordant autant d'importance que
ce goût aux impacts
enfin de qui se passe quelque chose
s'ils avouent passer à la suivante
et honnêtement ça va nous arriver plus
souvent ex amie ou quoi mais on sent
vraiment le truc c'est que je m'en rends
compte en fait s'il ya un ordi et du
niveau pour le voir en fait face à ce
sens général et la 2d dans tous les cas
je m'en fous royalement q vous allez
jouer sur lynch est ce à une époque
assez souvent va de temps en temps tu
reçois un message à vous avez récupéré
12 points parce que vous savez je
rencontre un tricheur fait une belle
jambe tu t'en fous bout
[Musique]
alors du coup julien c'est sûrement la
dernière partir du tournoi qui va
essayer de le gagner vite il reste
combien d un tac tac tac hockey
sacrifier une kalach ville a un très bon
contre je vis ici dans le cavalier très
puissant il joue bien julien je viens
bien sûr son gouvernement
et du coup est ce que comme il peut se
faire rattraper ainsi qu'avec bike
barbarian gagne par la mairie c'est sur
ah ouais en fait il faut peut-être même
mieux qu'ils finissent pas la partie
pour lui parce qu'il aura un meilleur
ratio gain que barbarian s'il finit pas
parce que du coup c'est bien ma vanne
marque deux points c'est ça ouais ils
seraient illégaux bon là après julien
qui de façon un peu trop au risque de
perdre alors là il vient de de gagner
une pièce sur la lentille petit enfilade
sur la dame dans la grande diagonale
donc du coup là normalement champions
qui ne crée pas l'exploit why are le
niveau du de l'ordi confie j'ai joué
était vraiment enfin il m'a fait un
sacrifice était vraiment jolie pour la
peine d'augmenter appris des trucs
ouais ouais non vraiment c'est beau ce
qu'il a fait on a une perf notre ami de
mona qui a concédé le nul 1 tanit tué
1500 doute ce qui n'est pas dans son
assiette avant ce tournoi
ouais julien c'est ça fait combien de
jours qu'il est bien il est bien en les
tournant il faut vraiment bien julien en
fait je déménage qui fait la reine juste
pour qu'ensuite je joue ahidjo avec lui
encore rien dit là ça piou piou qui
souffre plus des quatre qui va tomber
dedans alors à temps par pareil on est
passé devant ce cas oui paris rebondit
au nombre de gardes partie en fait
ok oui donc l'abandon paris va tenir une
minute vingt sa série va essayer de
tenir puisque pour les pour lui ouais je
pense qu'on est comme la
nous participons pipe où il a la chair
tournée il n'a pas eu le camp adverse a
laissé filer la pendule en fait je pense
qu'il aura pas le temps à passer la
porte
oui clairement je pousse alors cinq
dames provenant il peut la gagner
ouais ouais je vais faire plein de
fonctions et donc et dont il va gagner
face à 56 m alors à part ces barbarian
fermathe du berger facile à 40 secondes
et et les appareils et les joue très
très vite
bobby fischer prête au jeu ouais mais
ils s'en fichent toute façon fait tu
joues dessous tempo est vrai c'est que
j'arrive à être attendent un parent est
de jouer mais ce qui risque de se passer
à partir atteint maintenant juste moi
qui fais pas gaffe avec les non
seulement il a fait ses comptes
il a tenté faut tenter des matches super
jeu des trucs comme ça la vraie montre
un ouais
oui c'est la troll en mode de toute
façon ou alors ils n'ont en fait ce
qu'il a fait c'est pas si bête il
essayait de jouer un coup pour faire nul
vite hein et du coup là nul est un
exploit mais c'est julien qui
l'emportent
c'est pas suffisant la belle victoire de
julien s'est plusieurs fois qu'il était
sur le podium quand wii n'était pas loin
il finit par y ait par marianne deuxième
est puceau qui quitteront d'un troisième
place qui a pas réussi à faire sa
première victoire au tournoi
ouais pas mal de monde c'était sympa
compagnie belle perf est très belle perf
une des grosses parties
la partie qu'on a vus c'était de givet
là contre le maître fide et notre fille
de loser du coup ouais il a vraiment
fait une belle game cruz grosse partie
quand même vraiment une grosse game donc
écouter le canadien était sympa un style
ouais ouais non c'était vraiment
vraiment très très cool d'écouter merci
d'avoir suivi l'arrêt dans notre
compagnie c'était cool et merci d'avoir
un chemin aussi et on se retrouve
sauf justement donc ce sera avec demain
sera fait il serait avec la mort
comme quoi du coup vendredi ok merci à
tous merci à tout le monde
bonne journée